hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute stehen sie mir nicht oder besser
gesagt wieder bei uns im wohnzimmer und
zwar wird die sanierer heute wieder
geschminkt was ist diesmal ausgesucht
das ist so eine kinderserie oder eine
serie für mädels und jedenfalls auf dem
ihrer sicht den charakter frankenstein
ausgesucht und das kostüm dazu das
passende haben wir schon bestellt das
hat sich schon an und ich schminke im
gesicht
ich habe vor kurzem schon samira als
toll geschminkt und ihr wart wirklich
alles sehr begeistert und ich werde
jetzt auch heute wieder die farben von
kilometer hatten mich viele danach
gefragt und zwar benutze ich die
wirklich schon seit drei jahren ich habe
vor drei jahren im globus-markt hier mal
so eine aktion gemacht mit kindern
gebacken und da kam auch eine visagistin
oder eine maskenbildnerin von geometrie
blk und hat mit den farben kinder
geschminkt das war eigentlich eine
richtig tolle aktion und wird auch den
spendenerlös damals an das kinderhospiz
in mannheim gespendet und bei den farben
ist es durch arbeit gern mit denen weil
die auf wasserbasis sind das ist ein
geringer anteil die sind sehr angenehm
auf der haut und markanter als super
einfach mit dem pinsel mit den händen
oder auch mit den schwämmen auftragen
und man kann sie als super einfach mit
wasser wieder abwischen was natürlich
sehr wichtig ist gerade bei kleinen
kindern und die farben sind vom institut
fresenius getestet und sind unbedenklich
für kinder ab drei jahren und ich denke
wir starten jetzt einfach mal was ich
auch ganz toll findet die kleine
verpackung das heißt ich kann sehr gut
dosieren sowie dazu und ich sage wir
starten jetzt oder also ich habe wie
gesagt die farben da brauche ich jetzt
grün rot schwarz und silber ansonsten
habe ich hier verschiedene pinsel in
verschiedenen größen und ein bisschen
qatar bruder aber dass zeitgleich wenig
zur wende
samira bekommt jetzt ein handtuch damit
das kleid jetzt nicht dreckig wird okay
weil hier und ja so das reicht schon
jetzt habe ich einen schwamm den habe
ich schon ein bisschen nass gemacht
wieder ausgedrückt und mit dem nehme ich
jetzt diese grüne farbe auf und grund
dir erstmal ihr gesicht
und für die shb erreichbaren stellen
nehme ich dann einfach noch einen pinsel
als nächstes nehme ich jetzt das setup
oder das gibt es nämlich auch in grün
da freuen sich alle mädels und mit dem
man nicht mit dem putter ich jetzt das
gesicht ab
als nächstes sind jetzt die augen dran
also der lidschatten
dafür habe ich jetzt ganz normale
lidschatten und war in verschiedenen
farben
ich nehme zählt dieses lila das dunklere
unten leichtes prof jetzt fange ich mit
dem leichten rosa an abend so das kommt
jetzt hier innen auf das augenlid
dann geht es weiter mit dem lila
es kommt hier außen mit drauf da muss
man immer darauf achten dass man das
auch schön so ein bisschen verblendet
damit die übergänge einfach nicht so
hart sind
dann nämlich hier noch den dunkelsten
ton und der kommt hier aus noch in die
falte rein
und mit einem sehr dünnen pinsel da
nehme ich jetzt in sally pinsel kann ich
nochmal unten am auge entlang bisschen
lidschatten auftragen
für die autobauer nehme ich jetzt ein
bisschen schwarz und braun und fahrer
die noch ein bisschen nach
jetzt auch den lidstrich
den lippen dran normal
kommt noch eine umrandung umso mehr us
mund und dadurch erhält man so den
typischen cartoon charakter
jetzt kriegt samira noch sondern kleine
lichtreflex auf den lippen
für dann auch nochmal so diesem comic
charakter nämlich noch ein bisschen
lidschatten für die augen einfach noch
ein bisschen tiefer eindringen schwarz
und studien haben
kind hält haben jetzt weglassen aber
sanierer bekommt jetzt noch ihre wimpern
getuscht
mascara genau guck mal nach oben
erst die unteren und dann die oberen
dann verschmiert man sich nicht
für die wangen nehme ich jetzt noch ein
dunkleres grün zum spazieren und setzt
es unter die wangenknochen
und jetzt fehlt nur noch diese narbe im
gesicht jetzt frank ist ein
und wenn jetzt diese farbe aufgetragen
habt ich habe dort fließt ab oder drüber
das heißt die farbe ist jetzt auch ein
bisschen fixierten schmiert nicht mehr
falls ihr keinen satz ab oder habt könnt
ihr auch das ganz normale unternehmen
also das ist ein durchsichtiges
transparent oder einfach damit die farbe
die jetzt danach kommt nicht schmiert
kommt die nabe mit schwarz und mit der
silber drauf
jetzt kriegt sie noch hier an der nase
ein controlling gehe also einfach rechts
ist allerdings auch schon später
bestimmt nicht
und bereit für die haare und findest du
cool also sieht dieser reise ende
ausrede ich mal und ich finde das kostüm
auch richtig klasse zusammen übrigens
beim mais bestellt auch die perücke und
wo ihr die farben bekommen könnt das
schreibe ich euch noch in die infobox
und ansonsten hat sehr viel spaß gemacht
oder und zum abwaschen kann samira dann
einfach ein bisschen warmes wasser und
waschlappen nehmen oder einfach in die
dusche springen die farben gehen mit der
suche ein paar letzte oma und
erschrecken die oma oder ja machen wir
ja ich gehe mit im spiel
ok also viel spaß beim nachmachen und
wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal tschüss